today's video is brought to you by athletic greens
comprehensive all-in-one greens powder engineered
to fill the nutritional gaps in your dirt to
support your body's nutritional needs across the
four pillars of health gut health immune support
energy and recovery it's packed with 75 vitamins
and minerals and whole foods sourced ingredients
combining the perfect amount of micronutrients
absorption and taste to jump start your daily
routine you'd be hard-pressed to find a more
comprehensive powder supplement on the market now
you guys know i'm not exactly a fitness youtuber
not exactly a fitness person you're probably
not coming to my channel for squat tips but
i do like to still eat right and take care of
myself and athletic greens is that comprehensive
nutritional supplement that i know is going
to account from the holes that are blatantly
in my diet because i know it's not super
balanced just one scoop into the water bottle
in the morning it even comes it comes with
all of this stuff you got the water bottle
you got the scooper you don't take it out of
the packet like a savage they even provide this
nice little tin to put it all in keep it in
the fridge plus it's gluten free dairy-free
paleo vegan keto low allergen and low calorie
there's less than one gram of sugar per serving
but despite that it does taste sweet and good one
of the things that i like about it is i i still
drink my coffee in the morning but i have a cup
of this along with it and it just makes me feel
like i'm being more healthy and i also feel like
the kind of energy from the coffee lasts longer
no idea if that's just in my head but it's
absolutely working athletic greens is the
perfect dietary supplement regimen so if that
sounds like the supplement you've been looking for
you grab your own immunity bundle that's one year
of vitamin d plus five individual travel packs
like this that come along with it those are
for free just go to slatedgreens.com forward
slash biographics or click the link in the
description below and now today's video
the americans wanted him dead the mexicans wanted
him dead stuck in the middle between two larger
much more powerful forces apache warrior
geronimo strived to preserve his people's
way of life he did this the only way he knew how
by fighting make no mistake about it despite the
image everybody has of geronimo's this old calm
and wise man he spent most of his life fighting
and killing those who got in the way of his band
of apathy he wasn't the kind of tribal chief to
advocate for peaceful solutions in fact geronimo
was never a tribal chief at all he was a medicine
man and a warrior but people gravitated towards
him nonetheless he was a natural-born leader who
guided his people through the apache wars the
most violent and turbulent time in their history
the most commonly accepted information says that
geronimo was born on june 16 1829 in turkey creek
arizona somewhere near the gila river he belonged
to the bed encouraged band one of the smallest
groups of the chiriquaha apache his birth name
was guyatley which meant one who yawns he adopted
the spanish name geronimo later in life although
we're not exactly sure why we'll go with the most
popular and most badass reason which said that
he was such a fearsome fighter that many mexican
soldiers began praying to saint jerome when they
faced him in battle the apache warrior liked the
way that sounded and accepted it as his new name
dromo was a man born into conflict the apache
had been warring with the spanish for hundreds of
years and the violence continued with the mexicans
once they gained their independence in 1821 as
a new state mexico was eager to establish its
territory so it lay claim to the land where the
donkey had settled as you might imagine the apache
disagreed with their claim and with no peaceful
solution in sight the only remaining option was
war when geronimo was young the apache chief who
served as the biggest thorn in mexico side was
named mangus coloradus as soon as geronimo reached
fighting age he started joining the apache gangs
on raids against mexicans led by mangus and
his more famous son-in-law kachise decades
later mangus colorado's meant as a very gruesome
and shameful end one that even geronimo called
the greatest wrong ever done to the indians but
it did not happen at the hands of the mexicans
or rival tribes but rather the americans in 1863
coloradus was taken into custody by the union army
after meeting under a flag of truce that night
the general in charge future louisiana senator
joseph rodman west told his centuries that he
had no intention of negotiating and he wanted the
apache chief dead by morning the soldiers first
tortured the imprisoned 70 year old colorados with
heated bare nets and then they shot him to
death and buried him in a shallow grave later
claiming that he tried to escape the next day they
concluded that they could stoop even lower if they
really tried hard enough so they dug up the body
cut off the head boiled the flesh off and sent the
skull to a phrenologist in new york despite
efforts from his descendants and historians
the current location of the skull remains a
mystery and a nice friendly reminder of the
american government's treatment of native
americans of course all of this happened
later but young geronimo also learns
pretty quickly not to put too much stock
in government promises during the mid-1850s there
was a tenuous peace between the apache tribes and
the nearby mexican towns after decades of violence
that left many dead on both sides by that point
geronimo had officially become an apache warrior
he had married a woman named lope and they had
three children together in march 1858 most of the
men in geronimo's band left on a trading mission
to a town that they called cascare better known as
janos in the state of chihuahua while the warriors
were gone the mexican army mounted a surprise
attack on the badanke band stealing all of their
supplies and slaying almost everyone that they
encountered in his memoirs geronimo recalled the
horrors that awaited him when he arrived home late
one afternoon when returning from town we were met
by a few women and children who told us
that mexican troops from some other town
that attacked our camp killed all the warriors
of the guard captured all our ponies secured our
arms destroyed our supplies and killed many of our
women and children quickly we separated concealing
ourselves as best we could until nightfall when
we assembled at our appointed place of rendezvous
thickered by the river silently we stole in
one by one sentinels were placed and when all
were counted i found my aged mother my young wife
and my three small children were among the slain
following the murder of his entire family geronimo
was left with a burning hatred for mexicans and
an urge for revenge that haunted him the most of
his life going by apache stories geronimo received
divine protection to assure him that his quest
for vengeance was righteous after he had set fire
to his family's belongings he went alone into the
forest to mourn their loss there he heard another
worldly voice that promised to guard him saying
no gun will ever kill you i will take the bullets
from the guns of the mexicans and i will guide
your arrows whether real or not the spectral voice
kept up its end of the bargain geronimo was shot
many times but no gun ever killed him on at least
one occasion the apache warrior ran out of arrows
while fighting mexican soldiers so he just charged
them with fire and fury smoldering in his eyes
zigzagging his way through the hail of bullets
and killing them all up close with his knife well
let's not sugarcoat this geronimon is bandovori
has killed a lot a lot of people and not all of
them were soldiers armed and ready for a fight
here's how just one of geronimo's raids went in
a summer of 1866 as told by the man himself i
took 30 mounted warriors and invaded mexican
territory we went south through chihuahua as
far as santa cruz sonora then crossed over the
sierra madre mountains following the river course
at the south end of the range we kept on westward
from the sierra madre mountains to the sierra de
saharipe mountains and followed that range
northward we collected all the horses mules
and cattle we wanted and drove them northward
through sonora into arizona mexicans saw us
at many times in many places but they could
not attack us at any time nor did any troops
attempt to follow us when we arrived at homes
we gave presents to all and the tribe feasted
and danced during this raid we had killed about
50 mexicans this is how things went for the next
15 years also the mexicans killed the apache
and the apache killed the mexicans in return
they were trapped in a vicious cycle of death
where each side felt justified in striking the
other either as revenge for a previous attack
or to stop a new one there was an attempt at
reconciliation in 1873 the apache and the
mexicans met at casa's grandes in chihuahua
sat down together and agreed to a peace treaty
just for a little moment it looked like it might
be possible to end the violence between the two
sides but in the immortal words of admiral akbar
it's a trap once the treaty had been signed the
mexicans brought out the mezcal to celebrate not
once turned down booze the chiricahua got nice
and drunk and when they were all wasted two
companies and mexican soldiers stormed the town
and massachusetts among the lucky ones who managed
to escape but it left his band of apaches severely
weakened and put an end to the raids for the time
being and if that wasn't bad enough he also had
to contend with a new threat from the other side
during geronimo's time the doncoe people usually
divided their time between the territories of
arizona and new mexico with occasional incursions
into the northern mexican states to conduct raids
at first this was all land that mexico laid claim
over but the landscape changed drastically during
the late 1840s thanks to the mexican-american
war after a decisive victory for the united
states the two countries signed the treaty of
guadalupe hidalgo in 1848 according to which
mexico not only recognized texas as belonging
to the united states of america but also ceded a
gigantic stretch of land that makes up most
of today's american southwest this included
the land of the apache and many other native
americans and with the california gold rush in
full swing by the 1850s the two sides were soon at
odds with each other as they fought over territory
surprisingly geronimo was not among the first to
take on the american army instead throughout the
1850s and 1860s other apache leaders such as
mangus coloradus and cochise were the ones who
resisted american encroachment we've already
mentioned how that ended for coloradans but
could she someone managed to avoid a similar
grisly fate after over a decade of fighting
the us army tooth and nail he signed a peace
treaty in 1872 and lived his last years quietly
dying of natural causes in 1874. during
the mid-1870s the government set up the san
carlos reservation in arizona and wanted to
move all the chiroqua apache there as you might
imagine being confined to such a single area was
anathema to many native americans who were used to
roaming the lands completely free it's not
like the reservation was particularly nice
either it was an arid wasteland where food
shortages and disease were rampant truly
deserving of the nickname that it earned hell's
40 acres in a shocking twist that nobody could
have seen coming many apache refused to go along
with this plan and immediately rebelled against
the u.s government preferring delivers outlaws
if it meant keeping their nomadic way of life
at this point there were three men the dachirokoar
apache turned to for guidance one was geronimo
who although not a tribal chief had earned enough
respect that his word carried a lot of weight the
other two were actual chiefs and the names were
and hazard the latter of these was the eldest son
of catrice and of the three he was the one most
willing to try and adapt to a new lifestyle if
it meant peace for his people he traveled to the
san carlos reservation willingly taking with him
about a third of the chiroqua afterward he even
went on a delegation to washington dc where he
quickly fell ill with pneumonia and died so not
exactly an auspicious sign for the apache american
relationship especially since rumors started
flying that taser had actually been poisoned
as far as juror and geronimo were concerned they
took the rest of the chiriqua and made their way
to new mexico unbeknownst to geronimo he had just
made a new mortal enemy john clum not that it made
much difference to geronimo to have one extra man
who wanted him dead but well who was john klum and
why did he have it in for the donkey warrior
well klung was the indian agent who negotiated
the deal to relocate the apache to the san carlos
reservation initially both juror and tanza were
willing to move but then geronimo came along and
talked ju out of it if klam would have managed to
get all the chirokua to settle in the reservation
peacefully it would have been a major boon for his
career and he would have gotten away with it so
if it wasn't for that pesky geronimo anyway now
klump's plan went to hell and he wanted the apache
warrior dead as a consolation prize it wasn't
hard for him to track geronimo down especially
after he got a few apache scouts to rat him out
geronimo and the rest of the chiroquah were on
the oyo caliente reservation living alongside the
warm springs apache led by chief victorio klum set
up a trap for the unsuspecting geronimo who had no
idea he was being pursued and managed to capture
him alive without the need for violence likely to
clums disappointment since he would have
appreciated it if the banonkoya leader had
given him a reason to strike him down right then
and there well he didn't and geronimo was brought
in shackles to the san carlos reservation where
klum's dissatisfaction continued undoubtedly he
was hoping for a speedy execution for the apache
rebel but he didn't get one maybe for the first
time ever bureaucracy saved the day his geronimo
sentence was delayed while the department of war
and the bureau of indian affairs bickered over
who had jurisdiction over the chirichua after a
few days dronimo saw an opportunity to escape and
he took it as it turned out klum didn't hate him
enough to go through all of that again so instead
he simply resigned from his post the early 1880s
were a very violent and active period for the
apache one that helped seal their reputation as
one of the most dangerous native american nations
in the united states on the run from the law many
chiroqua crossed the border into mexico and
hid out in the sierra madre mountains there
geronimo was joined by other famed warriors such
as chief nana and the ironically named fun they
often led raids along the border ranches wagon
trains merchants prospectors the apache attacked
them all without mercy or hesitation and usually
left no survivors to prevent their location from
being discovered even so the chiroqua couldn't
remain hidden forever and the trail of bodies
they left in their wake put them on a collision
course with both mexican and american armies
one way or another 1883 saw the violence between
the three groups come to a head first there was
the older more bitter rivalry between the apache
and the mexicans which ended in an all-out battle
in the mountains in the state of sonora as
geronimo scouted the enemy he heard the mexican
general instruct his men to kill every single
apache men women and children and warned that
any deserters would be shot on site with little to
lose geronimo signaled the start of the battle by
killing the general with a well-placed shot the
fighting lasted all day from sun up to sundown
with the mexican troops wavering and rallying
several times eventually a few chiricahua managed
to sneak behind enemy lines and set fire to the
long grass behind the mexican army the chaos
that ensued allowed the apache to flee into the
mountains geronimo claimed that that was the last
time he ever fought the mexicans surprisingly the
american army had an uncharacteristically tempered
approach trying to find a peaceful resolution to
their conflict with the apache sure they still
had a few skirmishes first they didn't carry all
that ammo for nothing after all but eventually
they negotiated for the chirokua to return to
the reservation this was mainly due to the man
in charge general george crook who was somewhat of
a civil rights advocate for native americans at a
time when such a position could sink a political
or military career there was begrudging respect
between him and the apache leaders they referred
to him as tan wolf and considered him a good enemy
and worthy adversary meanwhile crook described
the jurichoy apache as acuteness of sense perfect
physical condition absolute knowledge of locality
almost absolute ability to persevere from danger
we have before us the tiger of the human species
in his memoirs geronimo gave a much harsher
opinion on george crook he didn't trust him and
he thought that the general wanted him dead indeed
while it sounds like the two descriptions might be
at odds with each other that's not really the case
even some who wanted peace with the chiricahua
would have realized that they would probably
have an easier time if some kind of unfortunate
accident god drawn him out of the way since he
was often the main instigator anyway crook
never attempted anything of the sort so we
can only speculate on his true intentions what we
do know is that geronimo and some of his warriors
changed their minds and turned back while the
other chirichua were taken to a new reservation
called turkey creek eventually geronimo made
his way there about a year later but life on the
reservation didn't stick this time either in 1886
he instigated another escape even though this time
only a few dozen apache followed him perhaps
a sign that more and more of them were getting
tired of life on the run like before geronimo
defaulted to his tried and true tactic of
retreating into the sierra madre mountains crook
actually caught up to him one last time and
persuaded him to surrender again geronimo agreed
but became convinced that he would be hanged when
he reached the reservation so he fled for the
third time this was one failure too many and
president grover cleveland replaced crook with
a new general named nelson miles unlike crook
miles had no respect for the chiricahua he didn't
care if he brought geronimo back in shackles
in a coffin or with his head on a silver
platter as long as he got the job done
during geromo's last run he had less than 40
apache with them and only 18 of them were warriors
meanwhile general mills had 5 000 soldiers
hundreds of native american scouts and
a few extra thousand militia the scales were
just slightly tipped in the latter's favor the
chiricahua still fought but the writing was on the
wall for all to see surrender was inevitable but
miles found a particularly despicable way to hurry
it along by punishing the chiricahua who stayed
behind on the reservation over 400 of them were
arrested and sent to prisons in florida thousands
of miles away that way the free chirokua knew that
they would only see them again if they surrendered
finally in the summer of 1886 geronimo surrendered
at skeleton canyon for the fourth and final time i
will quit the war path and live at peace hereafter
he told general mills in his memoirs he said that
miles promised him not only that he would not be
arrested but that he would receive a house with
land and livestock of course genome wasn't stupid
enough to actually believe this but he hoped that
miles would at least respect the conditions of the
surrender which included allowing the chirokua to
see their families in florida however the
us government had a nice little streak of
broken treaties going so what difference would
just one mall make almost as soon as the deal
was signed miles declared it null reasoning that
geronimo had broken previous terms of surrender
in reality it is highly doubtful he would have
ever accepted anything other than a complete and
unconditional surrender the chirokua were now
prisoners of the u.s army bringing an end to the
apache wars even though minor skirmishes
still continued for a few more decades
following their arrest geronimo and the rest
of his band boarded a train never to return to
the land that they knew and loved first they were
taken to fort pickens in florida where they were
forced to do hard labor every day meanwhile the
first group of jericho was withering away due to
malaria so it was moved to mount vernon alabama it
wasn't until two years later that geronimo's group
was finally allowed to join them and when this
happened a wave of tuberculosis tried to finish
what the malaria had started during the mid-1890s
that chiricahua were relocated again to fort sill
reservation in oklahoma since the landscape better
resembled the environment they were familiar with
but by that point only 120 or so chirokua remained
that is where geronimo spent the last 15 years of
his life he tried his best to fit in he took up
farming he even became a christian and joined the
dutch reformed church but was kicked out because
he wouldn't stop gambling when he promised to
quit the war path and live in peace he meant it
even though he was frustrated and heartbroken
by the government's continued refusal to allow
him to return home he never took up arms again
instead geronimo made the best of a bad situation
by capitalizing on his notoriety as the worst
indian that ever lived that's how he built himself
as he toured the nation appearing at fairs and
exhibitions in front of stunned audiences who
had only read and heard horror stories about the
ferocity and cruelty of the infamous geronimo he
even took part in teddy roosevelt's presidential
inauguration parade it was all pure exploitation
of course but geronimo made more money now than
he had in his whole life he signed anything and
everything that had his signature on sold out and
so it was that the once ruthless killer became one
of the hottest brands in the country geronimo died
on february 17th 1909. he had been bucked off his
horse while riding home and the 79 year old spent
the whole night in the cold before anyone found
him by that point he fell with pneumonia and died
a few days later in recent decades a strange urban
legend has arisen which says that members from the
skull bone society at yale university robbed
the grave in 1918 and stole geronimo's skull
and that it's still in their possession truth
is that we don't really know what's inside the
grave because the arby filled it with cement in
1928 and placed a stone monument on top of it so
for now this remains the final uncertain
chapter in the life story of geronimo
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching